so I've got a binomial variable X and
I'm gonna describe it in very general
terms it is the number of successes
after n trials after n trials where the
probability of success success for each
trial is P and this is a safe this is a
reasonable way to describe really any
random any binomial variable we're
assuming that each of these trials are
independent the probability stays
constant we have a finite number of
trials right over here each trial
results in either a very clear success
or failure so what we're going to focus
on in this video is well what would be
the expected value of this binomial
variable what would the expected value
expected value of X be equal to and I
will just cut to the chase and tell you
the answer and then later in this video
we'll prove it to ourselves a little bit
more mathematically the expected value
of X it turns out is just going to be
equal to the number of trials times the
probability of success for each of those
trials and so if you wanted to make that
a little bit more concrete imagine if a
trial is free-throw taking a shot from
the free-throw line
success success is made shot so you
actually make the shot the ball went in
the basket
your probability is let me do this
yellow color your probability this would
be your free-throw percentage so let's
say it's 30% or 0.3 and let's say for
the sake of argument that we're taking
ten free-throws so n is equal to ten so
this is making it all a lot more
concrete so in this particular scenario
your expected value your expected value
if X is the number of made free throws
after taking ten free throws with a free
throw percentage of 30 percent well
based on what I just told you would be N
times B it would be the number of trials
times the probability of success in any
one of those trials times zero point
three which is just going to be of
course equal to three now does that make
intuitive sense well if you're taking
ten shots with a thirty percent
free-throw percentage it actually does
feel natural that I would expect to make
three shots now with that out of the way
let's make ourselves feel good about
this mathematically and we're gonna
leverage some of our expected value
properties in particular we're gonna
leverage the fact that if I have the
expected value of the sum of two
independent random variables let's say X
plus y it's going to be equal to the
expected value of X plus the expected
value of y that we talked about in other
videos and so assuming this right over
here let's construct a new random
variable let's call our random variable
Y and we know the following things about
Y the probability that y is equal to one
is equal to P and the probability that Y
is equal to zero is equal to one minus P
and these are the only two outcomes for
this random variable and so you might be
you might be seeing where this is going
you could view this random variable it's
really representing one trial it becomes
one in a success zero when you don't
have a success and so you could view our
rent our original random variable X
right over here as being equal to y plus
y and well you're gonna have ten of
these so we're gonna have ten Y's in the
concrete sense you could view the random
variable Y as equaling one if you make a
free throw and equaling zero if you
don't make a free throw it's really just
representing one of those trials and you
can view X as the sum of n of those
trials and it actually let me be very
clear here
when immediately went to the concrete
but I really should be saying n wise
because I want to stay general right
over here so there are n n wise right
over here this was just a particular
example but I am going to try to state
general for the rest of the video
because now we are really trying to
prove this result right over here so
let's just take the expected value of
both sides so what is it going to be so
we get the expected value of x of x is
equal to what's the expected value of
all of this thing but by that property
right over here this is going to be the
expected value of y plus the expected
value of y plus and we're going to do
this n times plus the expected value of
y and we're going to have n of these so
we have n and so you could rewrite this
as being equal to so this is our n right
over here this is n times the expected
value of y now what is the expected
value of Y well this is pretty
straightforward we can actually just do
it directly the expected value of Y let
me just write it over here the expected
value of y it's just the probability
weighted outcomes and since there's only
two discrete outcomes here it's pretty
easy to calculate we have a probability
of P of getting a 1 so it's P times 1
plus we have a probability of 1 minus P
of getting a 0 well what does this
simplify to
well 0 times anything that's 0 and then
you have 1 times P this is just equal to
P so expected value of Y is just equal
to P and so there you have it we get the
expected value of x is 10 times the
expected value or the expected value of
x is n times the expected value of y and
the expected value of y is P so the
expected value of x is equal to n P hope
you feel good about that